Are you as sick of winning as I am at this
point?
OK, now let's talk about Corona virus more
broadly and what's going on.
So we will do.
I'm not doing these daily anymore, but I'm
sort of doing these weekly or as the data
requires, the big picture on Corona virus
is it's really, really bad here in the United
States.
A lot of the world has already figured out.
January 20th, we got our first case.
South Korea got their first case.
They still have under 300 total deaths at
the last I checked.
We are obviously doing much, much worse than
that.
Around one hundred and twenty five thousand
deaths in total right now in terms of cases.
We are setting new records in terms of new
cases in the United States.
We had almost 60000 new cases in a single
day on July 2nd, about 55000 cases on July
3rd, some lower numbers over the weekend.
Typically, over weekends and holiday weekends,
the numbers decrease.
So we could have today and tomorrow some huge
numbers as a result of catching up on underreporting
over the weekend.
Now, a good thing is that death numbers are
down.
There's this growing idea on the right that
the evil left, the Marxist socialist left,
doesn't want to admit that deaths are down
despite cases being up.
Oh, I'm readily admitting it.
And there's about five or six different possibilities
about why it's going on.
I don't want a single person to die.
I don't want a single person to get coronavirus.
And I hope that that continues.
And we'll talk about why that may be going
on.
And a little bit in terms of cases, the hot
spots are Florida, Texas, California remains
a hot spot.
Georgia, Arizona, the Carolinas, Tennessee,
it's mostly red states, plus California.
Florida set a major record with the most new
cases in a single week of any state since
the start of the pandemic.
They had over fifty nine thousand cases in
a seven day period last week.
The Phenix Arizona mayor has admitted they
opened up too early.
This is not the Republican governor of Arizona.
This is merely merely an important person.
But what I mean is they are speaking only
from their democratic perspective.
As mayor of Phenix, take a look at this.
We opened way too early in Arizona.
We were one of the last states to go to stay
at home and one of the first to reemerged.
And we reemerged at zero to 60.
We had crowded nightclubs handing out free
champagne.
No masks are 20 to forty four year olds, which
is my own demographic, really led the explosion.
And we've seen such growth in that area.
We're seeing a lot of people go to large family
gatherings and in fact, their family members.
We are in a crisis related to testing.
I was visiting a testing facility this weekend
and people waiting still eight hours.
Good for her for admitting it.
Friends of mine in Arizona say it's an insane
situation.
Hospital capacity is rapidly filling up in
Texas.
University of Texas Austin researchers expect
hospitals in Texas are in in Austin, rather,
will be over capacity potentially by the end
of the month.
The mayor of Austin says they're in trouble.
And a reality we're learning is.
So we learned early that governors have to
deal with the reality on the ground, whereas
Trump doesn't.
Trump can just say, we're putting out the
embers and everything's going great.
Governors have to deal with the real situation.
Some of the governors choose to ignore the
reality.
Like, for example, we saw this in Texas.
We're seeing it in Florida.
Arizona mayors doubly have to deal with the
realities that sometimes governors don't have
to deal with.
How many of our hospitals are full right now?
Do we have to start telling people in Phenix
that they've got to maybe go to Tucson if
they want to, if they need an ICU bed, for
example?
So mayors are increasingly sounding the alarm.
Now, let's get back to this question.
Why are deaths so low compared to these new
case numbers?
Because when you look at the case numbers,
we're having now bigger than we've ever had
before.
The death numbers are only a fraction of what
we were having in April and early May.
That's a good thing.
We don't want people tonight to die, but we
want to know why this is going on.
Deaths continue to trend down.
So there's a few possibilities we've discussed,
all of which are still on the table.
One is that there's just a lag between cases
and deaths as the hospitals get better at
treating people earlier in the disease.
It may take even longer to.
Be very sort of dark for people to die.
And so the deaths haven't yet happened from
a lot of these early cases.
The ideas you need about 19 to 21 days for
a case to become a death if it's going to
we're on day 17 right now.
So if the explanation is that we just haven't
seen the deaths yet from these new cases,
we would expect the deaths to spike sometime
in the middle or the end of this week.
We're going to watch that.
Another hypothesizes there's now a less deadly
strain, which may be more contagious.
In other words, it spreads more easily.
But it is less severe.
So it will cause fewer deaths per case.
That's an assertion.
We've not seen actual evidence of that yet.
We want to be careful.
Number three, some states could just be lying.
I mean, that that's the the you know, it's
it's a very simplistic explanation.
But from what we've seen in Florida and some
other states, it's possible states are seeing
more deaths, but they're simply lying about
it.
Again, we need evidence to really believe
that.
The fourth possibility is that increasingly
it's younger people now testing positive.
So even though the total case numbers are
going up, the number of people in the high
risk age groups are less likely to be getting
it now because they're staying home.
And so a lot of these young cases are not
ultimately going to lead to deaths.
Number five is increase testing means that
in general, you have less sick people getting
tests at an earlier point.
Tests were so difficult to come by that you
they were really restricted to people who
were much more ill.
Now, in those case numbers, you have people,
but you're capturing more of the cases and
a lot of those cases are less severe.
That's a possibility.
And the number six is some combination of
these factors and or something that we don't
yet know.
So we're going to keep watching it.
I have no desire to see deaths go up for political
reasons.
As I've already told you, the case for removing
Donald Trump is crystal clear without a single
additional death.
And we will have certainly in the next 72
hours, a lot more information about whether
we can cross some of these possibilities off
the list or whether they are a likely or realistic
hypotheses.
Big announcement today, next Tuesday, OK.
Tuesday, July 14th.
We have two things going on.
The third David Pakman show chess tournament.
OK, Tuesday night, 8:00 p.m. Eastern, third.
David Pakman show chess tournament.
We're doing one a month.
That will be the July tournament.
And and and and very exciting.
We will have a huge one day membership special.
You don't have to play the chess tournament
to get the membership special.
We took unfortunately, at the end of June
last year, we had a ton of members sign up
because of a promo.
We ran a lot of those yearly memberships came
up for renewal in the last week.
And because of the virus, a lot of people
were unable to renew.
So we unfortunately had like our biggest three
day loss of memberships that we've ever had.
So next Tuesday, we're going to try to get
some of these folks back and bring in new
people so we will have a single day membership
special.
On Tuesday, we will also have the chess tournament
that day, a mix to be notified about both.
Just get on my mailing list, go to David Pakman
dot com top right of the Web site.
You can subscribe to the mailing list.
Very, very exciting.
Let me know what's going on in your state
in terms of the virus.